[Music]
maybe some people then kid thinking when
I think about Peru I think about my
family and my childhood it was probably
the happiest time of my life I didn't
worry about anything
I was happy although I had nothing look
Lee Sang only darkness to happen
Enrique Servan was born in 1970 in the
Peruvian capital Lima he was the second
youngest of eight children in the 1980s
Peru was subject to unrest by terrorist
guerrillas Servan could see no future
for himself there so in 1989 he came to
Berlin
[Music]
they got a voice bin and been this in
hours Linda no matter where I am I'm a
foreigner whether I'm in Peru or here
I'm the guy from somewhere else
purely that's it always makes me sad
isn't here in Germany in Berlin I played
a homeland for myself Chavez my feel
very good here about it and I think
Germany has become a part of me once
Tinka stolen and took for me is to
finance his university studies cirebon
worked as a dishwasher he planned to
become an architect but he had so much
fun working in restaurants that he
trained three years to become a chef
[Music]
in 2010 he opened Serrano his first
restaurant
[Music]
Cohan the rush of emission is framed as
I was used to cooking my family cooked
every day and my mother taught us it
wasn't a challenge for me to help out in
the kitchen so I just thought I like
this each other and it's a sensible John
that rescue fit yeah on to that is our
infinitive the roof
[Music]
vilmer stork is a lively district in the
west of the city there are lots of
different restaurants here
[Music]
sir Vaughn's idea was to introduce
Berlin to his homeland Peru
his restaurant has a modern not a
traditional design but some of the
embellishments were made in Peru
zone rasigan where one shell restaurant
boys professional kickoff there was no
Peruvian restaurant with professional
cooking and something of a European
ambience captors nomination so I thought
he's dr. Reimer genuine Peruvian and I
was convinced that a foreign restaurant
in Germany should be authentic did our
in island Austrian restaurant for hands
and mousse Peruvian cuisine is very
diverse and often very spicy
in the beginning serve on had to win
over his German clientele
one of his main dishes is ceviche a
Peruvian specialty jazzed up with hot
Peruvian peppers called rocoto
what's special about Ricardo is its size
you could confuse it with a red bell
pepper the difference is the black seeds
which are extremely hot it would be
dangerous just to eat it by itself at
least remind us our fossil named ceviche
is marinated fish you can use white fish
like croaker cod or sea bream ceviche is
more than just a dish in Peru in 2004
the Institute of culture made it part of
the nation's official cultural heritage
ceviche is light fresh and very healthy
it only has around 300 calories per
serving the fish is cubed and marinated
in lime juice that breaks down the
protein just as fermentation does thus
the fish is slightly pickled not really
raw ceviche is usually served with yams
and corn kombucha gusta hacer para
nuestro ceviche traditional espero que
les guste web religion